I want to pull up this tweet we were
just talking about how Elon said my
pronouns are prosecute slash fouchy and
in a lot of ways elon's filling that
void that Trump filled I gotta Wonder
did Elon look at what made Twitter big
saw that it was Trump and then said If
I'm going to fix this platform we need a
new trump-like figure so Twitter was
actually dying then Donald Trump starts
running for president starts tweeting up
a storm and all of a sudden Twitter just
takes off
then when Trump is out Twitter starts
going down Elon comes in and now he's
doing very similar things tweeting
things that rile people up posting memes
responding to people he is very much
filled that void on Twitter of what
Trump was so we have this interaction
that went viral over the weekend
Elon Musk said my pronouns are prosecute
slash fauci and Scott Kelly the
astronaut says Elon please don't Mock
and promote hate towards already
marginalized and at risk of violence
members of the lgbtq plus Community they
are real people with real feelings
furthermore Dr fauci is a dedicated
public servant whose sole motivation was
saving lives and Elon said I strongly
disagree forcing your pronouns upon
others when they didn't ask and
implicitly ostracizing those who don't
is neither good nor kind to anyone as
for fauci he lied to Congress and funded
gain of function research that killed
millions of people not awesome in my
opinion
concise holy smokes he got the joke in
there
and the pushback of the narrative yeah
and so fauci was working with what Eco
Health Alliance and uh what's that Peter
Peter dashik and they were sending money
was it what um fauci's company fauci's
government it was like his National
Institute Donald Trump approved jaina
function work and as soon as he did Dr
fauci in his office authorized it with
Echo Health Alliance and Peter dazak
who's alleged to be uh working with the
CIA to do it in Wuhan China specifically
at the level three laboratory of
virology there where they worked on uh
activated weaponized uh coronavirus
that's all confirmed yes okay so then
when he went under Congress to testify
Anthony fauci uh he testified and said
we didn't do gain a function he lied he
lied he lied yeah but but he was
redefining the word he was trying to use
semantics hold on he outright lied like
it wasn't even that he just straight up
lied and then Rand Paul actually pulled
up the study where he's like it
literally says here gain a function it's
one thing if the study said we're doing
research with viruses to do X Y and Z
it's another thing when the study
literally says gain of function research
and then in fact she's like no no yeah
Barack Obama specifically banned it and
and Dr fauci couldn't do it and and the
government couldn't do it under Barack
Obama because Barack Obama said there's
too many inherent risks towards making a
virus as lethal as possible but the
point I wanted to get to with this is
how Elon Musk has become a more
articulate Trump on Twitter you know
what I mean
yeah he's not American so there's no
fear of him running for president so I
don't think the Deep State's too
concerned he is an American but he can't
be the president he's not a naturalized
citizen he's a citizen but he's
important he wasn't born in the United
States so he's not available to run for
president so I think that the
establishment may not be nearly as
concerned about Elon as they are about
Donald Trump I don't know he started
releasing their Communications yeah and
Elon did more when it comes to the
Battle of free speech than any
Republican in the recent recent decade
ever ever did anything
go ahead good well I'm gonna I'm at a
Crossroads kind of where I'm like what
do we do do we side with the liberal
economic order or do we decide with the
bricks the Chinese economic order
neither or is there a third op there's
another option just a decentralized
world yeah you don't have to decide what
a superpower all the time you know you
don't have to side with an Overlord you
don't need an Overlord Ian you don't
need a government
you don't need people telling you what
to do you could do you could focus on
yourself and you could decentralized
I'm real romantic I'm I'm really
romantic for anarchism like I I don't
I'm not the guy that's like I think that
anarchism is the right solution for
every but we should be striving towards
but it is it is a good goal to have
exactly voluntary interactions and all
interact in all human interactions is a
good goal to have exactly we should
always strive for that United the United
States is people say the United States
is gonna no no the United States are
doing things because it's a bunch of
State it's not an entity it's not it's a
bunch of states that have opted to work
to the federal government is an entity
that is independent and separate from
the city states so to say the United
States are is no longer accurate because
you're talking about what the United
States federal government one entity is
doing I see the largest Hawaii Luke
likes Ian because Ian gives him a layup
that's why I'm here baby I'm playing
support yeah regeneration he
which Overlord should I pick and then
Luke does the the more you know actually
big question I've been so concerned
about the liberal economic order since
Zeitgeist since 2005 and six and I'm
like oh the buildings came down in a
free fall near Free Fall what the hell
so they were like almost my enemy in my
mind I'm like how do we but now I'm
seeing the Chinese there's more than one
economic order well so you want to get a
little weird think about this the the
the the and this is something that I've
been thinking about that I think Elon
Musk is doing he's looking at Twitter
starlink uh SpaceX it's all one thing
for him
as much as they are different businesses
essentially he is laying the groundwork
with those companies
to make interplanetary life possible
and that's they all will they all have a
certain Synergy together if you can get
big heavy stuff off of the planet and
get to Mars and you can colonize Mars
and you then you could put starlink you
would want to put starlink around that
planet as well because you would want to
be able to communicate he all of this
stuff works together
if you're thinking how do we make human
beings interplanetary or multi-planetary
is Mars and then from there on I don't I
don't think I think Twitter and starlink
are rudimentary I'll stop people are
saying that Twitter would be a really
great way to communicate if you're uh
interplanetary because they're short
burst messages you can say a thing and
then after a few minutes it lands
everybody sees it it lasts forever so
it's you know effective for
interplanetary communication I disagree
I think entangle a quantum entanglement
is how we're going to do interplanetary
communication or sympathetic vibration
using crystalline uh communication like
you vibrate one crystal in Earth's
atmosphere and then the Crystal and Mars
atmosphere starts to vibrate to it's
different than entanglement but all
that's none of those things have the
technology now elon's taking existing
technology and pushing it as far as it
can go seeing how much we have and
really kind of TR it's really testing
where is the line that the things that
we have uh can perform a a task and what
needs to be innovated to perform tasks
that need to be done to allow for
internet Interstellar travel I like Elon
because he's like take what we have and
start he went he's at least using
Rockets to get us out there it's not
cost efficient we need an elevator we
need space elevators and this graphene
material looks like it'll be the tether
I knew graphene was coming yeah it was
super strong tether material you can
send stuff up into orbit all day you
know like 60 different elevators going
up and down all day at this one base
station in Mexico or something everyone
drink uh he said it also I found it very
interesting to see him tweet after this
Elon Musk specifically saying quote the
branch covidians are upset specifically
talking about the The covid Cult of
people who wanted lockdowns who wanted
restrictions who wanted to mask everyone
who wanted a procedure to be forced onto
everyone they're still pushing for it
and those people represent a lot of big
interest especially when it comes to Big
Pharma especially when it comes to the
corporate media and the government
working for big Pharma that is
essentially their marketing arm right
now so seeing him push back against this
he also had a meeting with the Stanford
Professor that was censored for trying
to stop the lockdowns he also is talking
about starting a new science board on
Twitter that's going to be able to judge
information and actually call it out for
for being either honest or dishonest so
he's pushing back against a lot of
powerful people and when you truly to
look do look at what he's been doing
especially with the people that he has
freed especially with the people that he
is allowed to still have a voice on a
platform that is relevant more than ever
this is a progression towards free
speech and and I think it's it's the
right road to be on and if there if he's
unraveling all of this on Twitter just
imagine what's happening at alphabet
what's happening at Tick Tock what's
happening on Reddit what's happening on
Facebook on Instagram you can only
imagine as of course these organizations
all work in unison when it comes to
stifling descent Banning people and
censoring ideas that they they don't
like which they work in tandem with Elon
just tweeted follow and a rabbit emoji
yeah follow the one on the rabbit hole
is that a white rabbit so he's been
talking to yeah Ian miles Chong says
although all the way down the rabbit
hole Yeah
I wonder what he's got coming next you
know what you're saying well he's also I
gotta I gotta say one thing in regards
to this
the Twitter files have shown in order to
censor someone with more than 10 000
followers and and people who are high
profile needed special teams to
intervene
this means that the word groomer the
Banning of James Lindsay were direct
manual intervention this means that they
have conversations about James Lindsay
and why they banned them and when they
suspended my account for having said
groomer about an adult man who was
showing sexual images to children
they locked my account and I have 1.4
million followers that means I would I
would I'd be willing to bet it was Joel
Roth himself
saying okay apply a ban on his channel
until he deletes it thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time